let's talk about swella Bravo and what
is the labor party's position on this is
it just simply an opportunity for you to
give a bit of a kicking to a prime
minister who's been in the job for for
24 hours or are the most serious
security concerns here
well look the Home Secretary is the most
serious job you could have in our state
this is a person who makes judgments
about terrorism and counter-terrorism
who makes judgment about very very
serious offenders and whether they
should be allowed out of prison and for
that reason it's someone who
um I'm afraid judgment is critically
important now we find out overnight
that Sue Ella Braven has been engaged in
multiple breaches not just one that she
sent from her private email account
um to back benchers wives and others
um documents that were effectively
official confidential or sensitive I'm
afraid this is a lapse of judgment that
quite rightly she was sacked for the
question is why was she brought back
what was the advice of the cabinet
secretary to the Prime Minister when he
suggested that she should be brought
back he should share that advice but
it's clear to me that she should be
sacked and there should be a full
inquiry into what's going on I mean
clearly the the reason for her
resignation sacking you've just heard me
the Tony party chairman having a better
disagreement over over which it was but
if she did step away from her position
and that she has and she has reflected
on her mistakes it doesn't Mr highly of
a point doesn't everyone deserve a
second chance at some point
a Home Secretary making decisions about
terrorism isn't allowed to make mistakes
I hope secretary making a decision about
serious criminals and whether they
should come out he's failing to register
six items
can I finish the point whether they
should come out of prison serious
offenders isn't allowed to make a
mistake I'm afraid this is an
unacceptable breach but more importantly
the new prime minister said he would
govern with Integrity professionalism
and accountability where is the
accountability what is that advice how
is this about integrity and how is it
professional that someone who sacked
after six days is brought back into the
government why because it's in his it's
in the interest of the conservative
party not because it's in the interest
of the general public or our country so
what then is labor party going to do
about this when you're asking for
officials advice to be published I mean
the government will resist that as
strongly as they possibly can so I'm
just wondering how you move forward with
this story apart from you know next
Wednesday
well look let's be clear there have been
many breaches of the ministerial code
over the last uh several years uh by
this government and its predecessors on
All Occasions we've raised those
sometimes we have eventually uh seen
that ministers leave their office I
suspect that Sue Ella Braven is her
position is now looking very very
fragile indeed sure but I'll repeat the
point I mean you would answer once I was
rudely interrupting you I mean you know
an inquiry once found you guilty of
registering six interest at least six
eight you're failing to register six and
16 interest on time including payments
for tickets to American football and
boxing matches in London now they said
that this was an inadvertent mistake I
will concede that but you got a second
chance so why shouldn't she because I
I'm not home secretary I'm not running
the government just remember let me
finish this final you ask me the
question let me finish the point come on
I was tardy I apologize that I was not
sending secret official documents to
strangers that that is totally
unacceptable and it does not compare
with that breach that I that I was found
guilding a few others were earlier in
the summer let's reflect on where where
labor and the conservative the
conservative government are at the
moment we of course had rescue next
first pmqs yesterday by gen by General
by General claim he felt to have done a
decent job certainly significantly
better than than the less trust when she
was at the dispatch box but what was
your review of what took place across
across the commons chamber yesterday
well look let's be clear Liz truss was
staggeringly awful most new Prime
Ministers get a bounce she was so bad
that her bounce effectively came to the
opposition uh so that the you know the
bar was pretty low uh for Rishi sunak uh
look the truth is the key thing is there
were several questions that he did not
answer uh it was put to him why Sue Ella
was back he didn't answer the question
uh there were questions about why he
said previously that he had moved moved
money from deprived areas to to to to to
parts of the country that didn't need it
he didn't answer those questions and of
course it's our job as opposition uh to
be pretty exacting to put him to the
test and kirstama will continue to do
that over the coming days what is clear
is he still has a divided party he says
that he's trying to unite his party
that's why he's bought sowella Bradman
back this is not in the National
interest it's in his party's interest
just reflect on on some of which we
heard in the chamber yesterday some very
warm somebody actually moving uh
testimony to to Rishi sunax status as
the first British British prime minister
of British Asian origin and I do wonder
what your view is then of that tweet
from your colleague on the labor benches
Nadia Witham which said this Rishi
sunaka's prime minister isn't a win for
Asian representation he's a
multi-millionaire who is chancellor Cuts
taxis on Bank profits whilst overseeing
the biggest law a drop in living
standards since 1956 black white or
Asian if you work for a living he is not
on your side what did you make of that
my view is very very clear my parents
arriving here as part of that windrust
generation in the same era as I think
Rishi sunax grandparents arrived they
would never have dreamed that we would
have a moment where a man of color is
stepping outside number ten of course
it's a hugely significant moment I think
there's been advances
in terms of in terms of diversity she's
been directed delete the Tweet after it
drew considerable backlash and there are
no suggestion that she will have the
whip withdrawn what is your view why am
I not I'm not the chief whip that is a
matter for that is a matter for our
whips I think she has apologized she's
deleted the Tweet uh no spokesman
spokesman from his work I'm told the BBC
a little earlier she would not apologize
for the tweet and had not been asked to
do so by the party I'm just the reason I
push on this is that we also heard Rupa
Huck
um obviously during during the
conference season calling the former
Chancellor quasiquating superficially
black because of his upbringing I'm just
beginning to wonder whether or not the
labor party has a bit of a problem when
it comes to race oh look come on that's
patently ridiculous let's be clear let
me let me tell you why so I'm sorry
superficially black and you're laughing
let me tell you why the labor party
Remains the most diverse party in
Parliament uh Rishi sunat becoming prime
minister is a Monumental and wonderful
thing it builds on Tony Blair bringing
forward people like
Valerie Amos
uh it builds on all of that we have our
Scottish leader uh is a man of color of
course so it builds on all of that all
of our political parties are now diverse
that is something I welcome
said what she said then well look both
of them have apologized they were wrong
to do that all I don't think that just
has you will always find in all
political parties people on the back
benches will say things that they later
regret particularly in this age of
social media but let us Delight in the
diversity the visible diversity that we
see in Parliament across all political
parties and whilst we have here I do
want to to spend a little bit of time on
your brief and of course Qatar and the
comments that we had yesterday from the
foreign secretary Ed James cleverley
appearing to suggest that that gay
football fans traveling to the World Cup
needed to be you know pay additional
concern to the cultural concerns of the
katanis what did you make of that well I
thought that his statement was tone deaf
uh look isn't the problem with the FIFA
though for awarding the World Cup to
that country let me finish the point
look we want a situation in which all
athletes and all members of the public
that go and enjoy the World Cup uh in
Qatar are able to be there and be
themselves whomever they love to to hold
the hands of their loved ones to to walk
up a road to to sit to sit and watch and
and be who they are and and and the idea
that they should hide which is the
implication of what James cleverly said
hide who they are is totally totally
unacceptable and it's why uh I I think
it isn't right
um for members of parliament to accept
Hospitality
um uh to go to Qatar given their record
not just on issues of lgbtq Rights but
also uh the way that they have treated
migrant workers David always good to
have you in the studio thanks for
joining us